Speaker 1: I have an example for you today.
Of totally backwards morality and bankrupt
principles, they're not even really principles,
quite frankly.
Fox News anchor Martha MacCallum bemoaned
a free lunch program in New Jersey, saying
there are kids who might grow up thinking
school lunch is actually free.
Can you guys imagine?
Can you imagine if a kid grew up thinking
school lunch is free?
It would be terrible for them, everybody,
I guess.
Let's listen to Martha MacCallum.
This is like the worst of the worst of this
strict father morality ideology that we hear
espoused by some on the right and certainly
on Fox News.
Listen to this.
Speaker 7: One of the things that kills me
is that now that you know, there's a free
lunch program in New Jersey and it's for everyone,
even if you you don't need help to send your
child's lunch to school.
So those kids are going to grow up thinking,
well, school lunch is free, right?
And then God help the person who comes along
and tries to take that away.
I mean that that will never once that happens,
right?
Once it's baked in, they're never going to.
But it's
Speaker 4: important what you said, you're
going to pay for
Speaker 1: it with higher taxes and
Speaker 4: higher inflation.
And I think most again, common sense Americans
know this is not right.
They don't want big government socialism.
They don't want a welfare state.
Speaker 1: Where can you imagine?
So first of all, Martha seems sympathetic
to whoever is going to try to stop the free
school lunch.
Now there's a couple different things here.
How is it that we have public education paid
for through taxes, it's like prepaid in a
sense that free.
It's prepaid public education, but not the
lunch.
You add the lunch and now it's socialism idiotic.
I mean, the level on which these people operate
is is absolutely pathetic.
But why shouldn't school lunch be free?
And again, in a literal sense, the food's
not free, but people pay property taxes to
fund schools.
People pay property taxes for a lot of things.
There are some parts of the country.
It's municipality based in some parts of the
country.
Your property taxes include trash and recycling.
Pick up.
It's part of your property taxes.
We don't say it's free.
We say it's prepaid through property taxes
in some parts of the country.
I have relatives who live in municipalities
where property taxes don't include trash pickup.
You've got to do your property taxes and then
you've got to hire someone you know could
be 30 bucks a month, whatever to do, your
trash pickup and your recycling pickup.
In neither case is this is anything free.
Sometimes it's just included.
Sometimes property taxes pay for good schools.
Sometimes the property taxes people pay pay
for not so good schools.
If property taxes cover school lunch, what's
the big realization that's going to be devastating
for kids?
Just oh, the property taxes cover school lunch.
Also, school is mandatory.
You have to be there, but they don't have
to give you food at no additional cost.
Remember, it's not free.
It's paid for through property taxes you have.
It's not free at point of purchase to have
food.
When you're obligated to be in school, they
are.
There are kids who are depending on school
in order to eat.
By the way, I think it's important to mention
is it a good thing for kids to be thinking
that whether or not they have food that day
depends on all of this other stuff other than
just Did you come to school today?
Great.
You get lunch and remember, it's not really
free.
It's prepaid that to be accurate, it's prepaid
through property taxes.
You know, my mom didn't charge me for lunch
at home, but I didn't think it was free.
I realized she bought the food.
My dad bought the food right?
Imagine thinking that so-called free school
lunch is the problem, and not the financially
and not the fact that huge corporations sometimes
pay zero taxes despite profiting handsomely
handsomely.
Just such a backwards world and the disdain
the indignant Martha MacCallum.
Can you imagine God help?
She says.
God help kids who think they grow up thinking
that school lunch is free.
This is a huge part of the problem ideologically
in this country where we end up having to
put energy and time into these debates when
we could all just agree, like, Hey, school
lunch being prepared through property taxes,
it's no big deal.
Let's focus on something better.
Let's improve education.
And by the way, if you're hungry at school,
you're not going to learn, you're not going
to learn.
So there's a number of different ways in this
in which this just makes absolutely perfect
sense